salut romain dit donc mais des baronnies
alors c'est pas mauvais non mais qu'est
ce que tu fais avec thé je me prends ce
cancer du sang c'est le cancer féminin
le plus fréquent et le plus meurtrier
aussi il touche une femme sur huit au
cours de sa vie mais avant de parler de
l'agresseur on va faire un point sur ses
victimes
les saints en parle jamais assez
volatile les seins c'est quoi c est ce
que c'est mais comment c'est fait et
bien l'essence est composé d'une glande
mammaire qui a la particularité de voir
ses crédits du lait et qui est divisé en
une quinzaine voire une vingtaine de
loeb
disposer dans du tissu graisseux et
entouré de tissu conjonctif des
ligaments soutiennent l'ensemble et le
fixe au thorax au niveau du muscle
pectoral
ça c'est pour la partie interne bon de
l'extérieur vous savez sûrement à peu
près à quoi ça ressemble mais on va
quand même noter que ce qu'on appelle
communément le téton c'est en fait deux
parties le même langue et la partie
centrale et la réole qui est la partie
en forme de cercle qui entoure le melon
dans 95% des cas les cancers du sein
sont des adénocarcinomes c'est à dire
des tumeurs malignes développe
majoritairement dans les canaux qui
relie les lobes au mas blanc ou plus
rarement dans les lobes eux-mêmes ils
peuvent être non infiltrant c'est à dire
que la tumeur est localisée et ne s'est
pas propagé ou infiltrant c'est à dire
que la tumeur envahi les tissus autour
et peut même aller plus loin en passant
par les ganglions et créer des
métastases
il ya aussi d'autres formes de cancer
plus rare qu'ils peuvent toucher le
mamelon ou prendre une forme
inflammatoires il ya des traitements
notamment la chimiothérapie la
radiothérapie qu'on appelle aussi les
rayons
l'hormonothérapie mais aussi la
chirurgie qui consiste à enlever la
tumeur et les tissus qui ont été
touchées au tour c'est à dire parfois le
sein tout entier dans ces cas là ça peut
nécessiter une autre chirurgie de
reconstruction cette fois c'est à dire
une opération qui consiste à redonner à
la patiente hun sen d'apparence normale
ces traitements peuvent être lourds et
éprouvant aussi bien physiquement que
psychologiquement mais si le cancer est
dépisté suffisamment tôt il peut être
guéri dans 9 cas sur 10 le nombre de
cancers du sein augmente à partir de 30
ans mais le pic de risque se situe entre
50 et 74 ans donc c'est à partir de cet
âge là le dépistage systématique et mis
en place le programme de dépistage
organisé ça consiste en un examen
clinique
et une mammographie tous les deux ans
gratuitement la mammographie ça fait pas
rêver j'avoue mais les machines de
dernière génération sont censés être
moins douloureuse et surtout ça permet
de détecter des cancers précoces
avant même l'apparition des symptômes
moi je me crame ce programme c'est pour
les femmes qui n'ont pas de facteur de
risque particulier parce que si c'est le
cas c'est plus rapprochés mais pour les
autres alors comme ne pas être dans la
catégorie d'âge la plus à risque ça veut
pas dire qu'il n'ya pas du tout de
risque
le dépistage en vérité il est primordial
quel que soit l'âge surtout quand on
sait comme on l'a vu tout à l'heure que
plus un cancer est soignée tôt plus on a
de chances d'en guérir avec des
traitements moins lourds et le moins de
séquelles possibles sur une trame
d'ailleurs vous demandez peut-être
pourquoi toutes ces jeunes femmes se
prennent en main et bien tout simplement
parce que dès l'âge de 20 ans une partie
très importante du dépistage se pratique
seul ça s'appelle l'auto-examen des
seins ou auto palpation c'est simple à
réaliser
mais il faut connaître les gestes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment
camatte est originaire
moi je pense qu'une petite démonstration
s'impose l'auto-examen des seins je me
prends en main alors bel effort romain
mais dans la mesure où au moins d'un
pour cent des cancers du sein concerne
des hommes je te demander de bien
vouloir disposer on va laisser la place
à quelqu'un qui est vraiment concernés
et qui sait de quoi elle parle
volontiers cornet froisser ni facebook
youtube ta grand mère
cette démonstration sera effectuée sur
une terre de good practice
c'est bizarre parce que entêtons poilus
sur les réseaux sociaux ça passe crème
un téton sans poils c'est le diable pas
le sujet démonstration
[Musique]
tout examen ça se pratique tous les mois
sept à dix jours après les règles ou nda
de fixer facile à retenir en cas
d'absence de règles placez-vous torse nu
face à un miroir et commencez par
regarder vos seins vérifier qu'il n'y a
rien d'anormal comme un écoulement une
grosse heure quelque chose d'inhabituel
au niveau de la peau recommencer en
mettant vos mains sur les hanches
puis en levant les bras puis en vous
penchant en avant
ensuite mettez une main derrière la tête
et palper le sein du même côté avec les
3 d'eau du milieu où c'est comme les
scouts commencer par les scènes plus
parcours et toute la surface de la
poitrine en faisant une spirale terminée
par le mamelon est pressé le doucement
pour voir s'il n'y a pas un écoulement
anormal ensuite fait la même chose de
l'autre côté vous pouvez aussi faire
l'auto-examen allongé sur le dos ou sous
la douche
dans tous les cas si vous constatez une
grosse heure il sensibilité quelque
chose d'anormal ou d'inhabituel
contactez votre médecin je veux prendre
un jeune autres en main je me prends
part à moi je me prends moi et toi et
toi
[Musique]